hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsensors.com so in this video guys i
want to make a big update on amc and gme
let's go through everything that
happened this week we had good things we
had bad things so let's try to
understand what happened and see what
can happen next let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so i'm starting with amc
daily time frame first i'm gonna go on a
weekly time frame as well guys because
we have some information there so let's
see what happened i did my last video
guys last friday it was here okay we had
this hammer candle okay guys first the
good things that we can already notice
is that we start to have those reversal
signals that are coming repetitively
we had one two weeks ago we have one
last week
then we had the better income than
expected guys that happened on tuesday
so we had massive rally guys and
unfortunately this is not a good sign it
got rejected on a red day with huge
volume you can see yes this volume
so what does this mean guys okay so this
is bad sign so we have already a few
information two reversal candles
and
one
strong bearish day
on uh after good news right so buy the
rumors sell the news kind of situation
so
we have actually reached a period of
balance guys as you can see before it
was all for the best
now we have some bullish signals and
some bearish signals so
uh what is this telling us first let's
go on the weekly time frame because it's
quite interesting i think to look at
that and you guys can see
that it's the first time we have a green
week guys
four plus two percent
uh for the past one two three four five
six weeks guys so one month and a half
and before that we had this hammer
candle that was a nice reversal candle
by the way but it was not enough
and then it was again three wet weeks in
a row so basically it's a good sign
first for the first time we have a
positive week guys so this is also
showing that we have reached a period of
balance now if you check the 200 week
moving average once again you guys know
that this to this 200 period moving
averages are important all right so the
daily is more important okay but the
weekly is still important and we are
above guys we are finding some kind some
sort of support around 15
1507 for now
so this is the last bullish long-term
bullish
signal we have that is still intact okay
so this is just reminding us guys that
we are in a bull trend
for more than one year with a strong
correction i agree that happened since
uh june 21 for the past seven eight
months guys but uh it's still an uptrend
right we're moving higher we're making
higher highs and higher lows so just a
reminder that is i think important to
keep in mind uh whenever we are in such
difficult situations all right let me go
back on the daily time frame and here so
now we have identified that we're in a
period of balance okay that's good guys
uh this means
you know reversals which
always start with a breakout
uh happen
after this period of balance if you have
a breakout before this period of balance
happen for example here we have a period
of balance okay you can see on low
volume right you can see here guys low
volume
here
and the price action not moving much
okay so this is what we need for a
reversal here unfortunately the breakout
happened on the downside
okay and we moved lower so it's not
guaranteed it's going to happen on the
upside it just means that if it had
happened on the upside it would have
been a very good bullish signal that
would have been followed by a lot of big
money players which we need to be in the
trade with us all right guys apes alone
uh
you know they can squeeze
hedge funds they did
but the truth is that they were not
alone all right big money investors
maybe here they were alone but even here
i'm sure asset managers were implied in
the trades and here i showed you guys
that in the video i did last week uh
asset managers were buying a lot guys
during this whole period of time and
they stopped buying here and then we
dropped so we need those guys to be back
and those guys they're gonna follow this
you know typical situation of low volume
low consolidation then volume with
breakout by the way guys i'm building a
course i told you quickly that in my
last video but it's going to be released
very soon guys it's been you know a very
long time i'm working on that i'm really
trying to bring you guys the best best
methods that are gonna help you to
identify actually those trend shifts
okay using breakouts to course about
breakouts where i'm gonna talk about
volume volatility and momentum which are
the price action dynamics guys which are
key to understand what is happening on
this market and even if there are a lot
of traps by using the right way those
indicators of volume volatility momentum
you are able to avoid most of them okay
guys so if you're interested just click
on the link in the description of this
video and you're gonna
receive an email with a massive discount
whenever the master class is ready okay
so let's go back to what i was saying
guys so here the breakout
if it happens after this low volume
period that is once again important it's
going to be a good and reliable breakout
but for now i see this huge red bar
uh of volume so this is telling me that
we need more time all right guys this is
what i'm saying for quite some time
and i think that maybe one more week of
balance between 14.5 and 18
would be great for this trendline to be
broken you see the yellow trend line for
now i don't have that many reactions on
this trend line i have one two
three four
five you know it's not that many i'm not
sure the streamline is very visible but
if i have more reactions on low volume
just below the strength and then it's
broken then it's going to look very good
guys but i need to tell you about the
alternative scenario because for now we
have some bullish signals but we have
some bearish signals as well like this
big red day i told you guys and it's
been three four times we are testing the
14.5 level so you guys know that
whenever level is tested multiple times
it gets weaker so what would happen if
we break 14.5 we will very likely go to
the 12 level and the 12 level as i told
you guys last week is uh the consensus
of analysts so we don't really care
about what they said but asset managers
big money players hedge funds they do
all right so if those guys know that 12
is kind of the fair price they will
probably uh stop selling first and
increase their position this they would
start to be bias here so those guys
they're probably waiting here so i'm not
saying we're gonna go there but i'm
saying that if we do absolutely gonna
increase my position because i know that
we're gonna have some help some you know
good liquidity sitting there and waiting
uh to get in so what else can i tell you
guys yeah let's have a look at the uh
synthetic short
so bam bam
long
synthetic shorts
so we don't have any more synthetic
short guys okay because we have that we
have as much synthetic short as thin
synthetic longer which means put options
and call options and neutralizing each
other at this level of spot we still
have 19 of regular shots as of 14th of
january and i'm very curious once again
it's going to be really next week to see
what is the regular shot after those
hammer candles all right because i want
to see who got trapped in there is it
shows that covered what happened all
right i need to know
it's going to help me to analyze amc
better so i'm curious to see if this
regular shot is going to decrease or not
at 19 which is now at 19 percent as of
14th of jan iran yes so two weeks ago
three weeks ago almost
so yeah the we have no more synthetic
shot but guys we still have a crazy
option distribution all right look at
that
this are the options we have on amc so
you can see we don't have as many 145
strike as we used to because most of
them were on the gen 22 maturity we had
20 million of them guys i remind you we
still have 5 million of them so it's you
know 17 75 percent less but it's still a
lot and you can see this option
distribution is still totally uh
unnatural all right because we have big
big open interest on the 60 strike nutty
strike 145 strike all right guys so this
is telling us and anc is at 15 guys so
we're talking about you know
five eight times higher so this is
telling us that if we go there it's
gonna be a lot of trouble for option
market makers that's all it's saying and
it's also showing that the movement is
still strong all right whenever if
unfortunately uh we fail which i don't
believe all right but if we do
those options will no longer be there so
as long as those options are here the
movement is on all right this is what
i'm checking personally i'm an option
trader and i know that this is not
normal all right so everything that is
not normal tells me that something huge
might happen does it gonna is it gonna
happen for sure of course not but as
long as i'm gonna see that guys i'm
gonna believe in that all right
and it's still here but it's lower than
in 1022 so let's see if it gets bigger
and if option traders increase their
positions on those very high strikes are
not dtc is at two guys let's check what
it was before
amc
okay so the dtc is at two it was at 3
1.6 in october so it was at 3.5 in
november where when we almost squeezed
guys we almost got it right but just you
know
it didn't work out so now we're back at
two guys we need to rebuild that but we
know we need some time guys once again
my scenario is like a couple of months
it's gonna depend on the global market
i'm gonna post a video about spo and
triple q tomorrow go watch it
because i'm gonna analyze the global
market and as long as the global market
tanks amc will not squeeze by itself all
right once again to explain the negative
beta situation it just uh what happened
in the past was one red day on the
global market minus two minus three
percent amc plus 20 and then the global
market was increasing together with amc
imc amc will not squeeze without the
global market doing doing good but a
sharp move down in the global market can
trigger the first impulse on the way up
but then we need the global market
sentiment to be bullish for asset
managers hedge funds everybody involved
in amc trade either to cut the short
positions for hedge funds or to open new
ones all right guys so global and do
right now the global market is giving me
mixed signals
uh i'm not sure so check my video
tomorrow i'm gonna make a full analysis
but
i give it one more month you know before
at least before we go higher so same for
amc yes so the most likely scenario is
either we break out here or we don't i
don't know guys and then we oscillate
somewhere here and only here guys so
april june you know i know i'm delaying
that you know for almost one year but i
mean what can i do i'm just giving you
guys what is the most likely to happen
for me from here and the most likely is
that we need time okay guys and we need
time because we have those big volume
traded here that tell us bears are still
active all right guys so
that's it for amc neutral between 14.5
and 18 bullish above 18. uh below 14.5
we'll probably go to 12 then rebound
because we have a lot of buyers there
and then we need to see what's gonna
happen all right jme guys
so same thing i want to go on the weekly
time frame guys first bam and on the
weekly time frame what can we see so
first
we have a bullish week guys plus 4.5
percent very good
uh when the rest of the market was not
doing that good guys so gme resisted
very well it showed very good signs of
strengths
and look at that guys one two i'm
counting the red weeks one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
two and a half months of the market guys
so
is it gonna keep dropping maybe but what
we can say is that for the first time
since november 22nd we have a bullish
week so that's only telling us that we
have reached this period of balance that
is necessary for a good and reliable
breakout once again just like i'm
defining it in the course i'm building
guys and you know this is because this
is what is really happening all right if
you don't have this period of balance
okay like we had here once again we
broke out on the downside but this is
the period of balance that is needed
okay for a reversal to be sustainable
look here
it was the same thing each time guys we
have
a period of balance so here on the um if
you're going to log everything scale and
i check what happened in the past guys
it's always the same pattern that former
right you have look here for example you
know nothing was happening guys very low
volume and then we have a strong move up
okay guys so whenever you have a lot of
volume trading the market moving a lot
don't expect a sustainable reversal to
happen soon all right it's not working
like that we need the spirit of balance
so right now it's starting the balance
is between 87 and 115
so my take is that we stay in this range
for a couple of weeks right if we do
break out above 115 without the spirit
of balance then we'll probably get back
to it okay so we might have a few
bullish days but we will eventually get
back to it because bears are not ready
to let it go and for bears to be ready
to let it go you know we need to see
that they're ready by checking the
volume and the volatility low volume low
volatility guys okay so here
let me check on the daily and on the
daily time frame it's better than amc
first thing because we don't have this
huge red day
but the volume is not low this are low
volumes okay you can compare to the
period between 21 21st of december and
4th of jan right now they're higher okay
high volume means uncertainty
means there is a fight between bulls and
baz
and it means that
a reversal won't be sustainable right
now okay guys so we need time once again
same conclusion as for amc so my
scenario guys
is that we oscillate a little bit longer
here
okay
so once again look
i'm on the log scale if i go on a
regular scale the streamline is here so
i don't know which one to use at the
moment guys and i'm explaining that in
the course as well and to know which one
to use you need to check for those
consolidations okay if we have a nice
consideration here just like we do here
guys in this triangle just below the
trend line it tells you that this is
challenging to check for now i don't
have it so for now i don't pay attention
to this trend and i mean i do i check it
but i'm not using it for training
and i think the trend line to use is
this one because log scale is more
adapted for jamie and i'm expecting
something like this guys okay this is
what i want to see consolidation
below the strength line on low volume
guys important and if we do have that
then a breakout would attract a lot a
lot of investors especially asset
managers and you know the big money
players that you know use this kind of
signals to get in okay guys let's check
the
synthetic short
short interest uh yeah by the way i
forgot to tell you guys on emc the
maximum pain is
for february 18th is uh 21 yes okay so
this is the level that we might close
at
on the 18th of february so that it
creates the maximum pay for option
holders so option market makers like to
bring the price to this area
okay i'm refreshing the data guys
okay so what do we have first we can see
that we have something synthetic short
on jimmy 2.5
uh we have crazy options as well on the
upside so to get it it's going together
with amc we have a dtc at three let's
compare this dtc to what it was before
uh before it was four five six guys okay
so when we almost squeezed of course we
had a higher dtc right now it's three so
it's same thing as it's going in the
same direction we need time
bulls need to rebuild you know the big
synthetic shot they had by buying cool
options i don't say it's good to buy
cool options guys don't
misinterpret what i'm saying i'm just
saying that if there are a lot of cool
options it's
putting pressure on option market makers
that's all i'm saying don't buy that for
now all right it's not the right time to
buy call options i don't think so unless
you sell some puts but whatever it's a
complicated strategy i don't want to
push you guys to do that i'm just saying
that uh it's a sign for me that the
movement is on and we have it on gme
and it's putting pressure on option
market makers and the maximum pain is
around 120 so on the on february 18th so
it's a level that you know would make
sense for gme to close at once again
same as amc 21 so let's see it's a bit
higher
it would be great to close there so to
conclude on the price action on gme we
are in a period of balance between booze
and bears between 87 and 115
if we break out above 115 after some
more consolidation like we do have right
now so it just needs to continue on low
volume it would look very good we would
probably go to the 160 area where we
will find more resistance on the other
hand if we break out below 187 guys
which has been tested twice it would not
be looking good this would depend a lot
on the global market as well guys if we
have one more bearish uh cycle on the
global market 87 would be under pressure
and below 87 guys i don't have any
support level the next one is 40. so i'm
not saying we go to 40 if we break
out below 87 i'm just saying that booze
won't have any any area to gather their
strengths and to buy just like they did
at 87. so we would need to see where the
consolidation takes place and then we
would use that
same thing as we'll try to find a
breakout to know when it's time to get
in
okay guys so that's it for me i hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're gonna be the
first to know when i upload anything new
and stay close to flow i see you guys